all right david
yes
david uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i grew up in beaver
falls pennsylvania which is famous it's
called joe namath's country joe name is
a famous football player came from there
from the new york jets
we all remember joe
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents
yeah i had a difficult childhood my
father was
abusive he was the twice the grand
nights of the
the knights of columbus but on the other
end at home he was he was very strict
they were very strict
and so i was abused but i come out of it
and that i i left a couple times and i
came back and tried to piece it together
but
it didn't work
and so
i went back out and uh
i was working captain jim's supper club
and
i decided to call rodney dangerfield so
you you're a performer yeah i was an
impressionist
question as comedian yeah
so i decided to call rodney dangerfield
and he said hey
what can i do for you
just like that
and we hooked up and he helped me to
write one-liners
some of those famous one-liners that you
hear from him
came from me and like most comedians
that uh
neurotic hurtful life or whether
whatever didn't destroy us build us
in fact bill moyers when he was
interviewing joseph campbell and the
power of myth
he said when i used to think bad about
my father he said
that was the single most important in
your person in your life because you
were able to deal with what you deal
with and i have the strength because of
him
so the adversity you went through with
the with your father yeah that bro
yeah i got in trouble
i was on the streets
i uh
turned some people in that were involved
in the shooting
and uh
i was the fall guy as
you know
so back to your start yeah with your
earlier life
when you were kid you wanted to be a
performer
yeah i i
used to watch ed sullivan it was one of
the few things that i did with my father
on sunday nights i watched ed sullivan
and saw all the great comedians and i
saw this guy will jordan
he did the first ed sullivan
and i saw him doing movies and one of
the things i used to do with my mother
was watch these old films and
i fell in love with on the waterfront
with brando and i started to do him and
i just started to do all the voices
but i started to do pieces of all the
other people that people weren't doing
impressions and that so uh
that gave me a little bit
to get out because from a small town you
don't go anywhere in that and then the
war hit in
and in the 60s and and that had a big
thing with everyone
and uh
i'm 72 now
yeah
did you have children
no no children
that that strictness from my family kind
of
uh prevaricated it went against things
and that i i didn't date and and uh when
i worked from the ged because i was
always getting in trouble
so when i was in school
i was able to leave and go to work but
then my father took all my money
but i was able to get over some of those
things because i asked for some
understanding of why people were the way
that they were and i found that my
father's father took his money and that
but eventually i run away to california
because of it and that and came to
california what age
first time i came i had turned 18
and they had a thing called youth fair
and i could go for 89
and i got a meal and that
and i went and i tried to make it there
but my father kind of messed up things
with that too because there were some
friends that i was staying with that he
he knew that were with the knights of
columbus so
yeah that that closed that off so i went
back and tried to piece things together
and i got in trouble with what i thought
was my family you know like
the mafia has a family where you're on
the streets
and you don't have much or anything and
you're trying to make it through and you
start to hook up with people so my
mistake was
reacting instead of acting i had to
learn how to be alone
how how to be strong and
and to start helping others
in different parts of my life that's
what saved me helping others
so your career as a performer
my career took off because i i was lucky
i i run into people that helped me i
didn't know the stage of who they were
were but uh they they said things like
like rodney said uh hey what can i do
for you and peter lawford said this is
peter's office what you want
and i would just ask him and people
didn't know who who i was
in fact i found out that they thought
that i was dea
and that so uh sometimes being
undercover or when i'm out in the
streets or people are wondering who's
this guy and he's clean and he's dressed
up
people stay away that i want to stay
away because i'm not interested in doing
the drugs
i'm trying to keep my brain together and
trying to get off the streets
you've been living on the streets here
in santa monica for how long yeah three
years i was on the streets before for
like a year but i made it out
i had a place that was worse in the
streets most of these people don't want
to stay in these places because these
places have bed bugs
they have mice
and they have a lot of people with all
these serious problems in the building
and people stealing just like on the
street
so the places that they try to get you
into my thing is
i don't want to be transitional i want
the section 8.
i want what i'm i'm entitled to after
two cancers and getting hit by a car
being knocked down recently
i'm trying to like go to court and get
some
relocation money and get away from all
this
but while i'm here i'm helping people
the best way they can that god sent me
in buddhism they say that you're right
where you're supposed to be
but i have a tough time with that
because i i know that i i can do better
if i keep myself clean and most people
don't know i'm homeless
then
i can look like the outsider helping
people
like you
where do you stay at night i stay
over there by tj maxx
and usually when i say something or
where i'm at they come to to roust me
or to threaten me or to tell me like
they're going to put me in jail
or or give me a ticket
and i'm in a place that's safe with my
ladies so i'm not moving i i go back to
it
what are the hardest parts of living on
the street hardest parts in the streets
are
dealing with the people
dealing with the understanding that
after a whole life of working that
there's the the people that don't want
to do anything or anything with their
life
the sufis and and raphael the ford's
book
teachers of gurjev
who he was a mystic people went their
understanding and they said
the commandments were not fierce they
were be and do
and
what would be the worst thing would it
be a murderer would it be a thief or no
there would be forgiveness it would be
if you didn't do anything with your life
if you didn't try you know
so
today i'll go to saint joseph's i'll go
over there and get my mail i'll call
this lady christina again who's with
people's concern and tell her that i've
got the paperwork again because my
wallet everything was stolen
so i've been up
up against some fierce things but i keep
going and luckily
i have this lady from the philippines
that has helped me through
because i i was lucky enough to to have
kaiser
and they gave me a place a couple of
times but then they threw me right back
on the street
and and and you have to start all over
again
are drugs or alcohol a part of your life
no no
i partied i partied heavy because i
partied with richard pryor
and i part and a lot of things in show
business so i did the quaaludes i did
all that
and uh
was lucky enough to recognize that that
was nowhere that that's just a band-aid
but they're giving us band-aids all the
time when i pass away they'll be
throwing in those toothbrushes and those
little things and that and they ask you
what you want and i say i want off the
street i don't want to be in these
places with these people
i
that don't want to do anything with
their life that have lost interest i'm
not putting them down i just tried to
give them some kind of incentive
and and then it can be better when i was
on probation when i was young i took
anything so that i would work of course
you couldn't be homeless in pennsylvania
because you would die you know you would
and that with the cold and and the
weather
so
mental illness is the real problem on
the streets i think yeah i i have
some you know anxiety and things that
i've worked with were my mental thing
i lost my wife because of it because of
my anger
and that part of that ukrainian
literature literature
that keeps me going
also can get in my way like when i'm
dealing with people coming over to me
i'm like the hoodlum priest
i'm like
the godfather out there
people give to me
and so i will give to them because it's
given to me like you you
will give me some money to help me
and i will help other people because i
know about full circle i lived with the
indians and uh
when i was in uh
different places i i've been lucky
enough to escape
and that but i come back i had two
scripts and i thought i would make
something happen and things happen with
my wife and i won't go into that i don't
like to talk about people
when they're not around to protect
themselves you know but
after 23 years of a marriage
it was time to uh
pick up the pieces and i didn't want to
have anything to do with anyone they
they gave me these drugs
my wife called
and said i wasn't eating or sleeping but
she was never there so they came and
took me in
and i got involved with this doctor
and the doctor said don't fight this
i'll help you to get your disability
and the disability that people think
helps can get in your way
when i went to try to get work the fbi
had on there that i was under criminal
investigation and i i couldn't get my uh
raising my voice because i get a little
angry with this stuff
with i was trying to get the census job
and some stuff i was willing to work but
uh
that thing and those things once they
hit in on you you you gotta kind of try
to bounce back or work your way around
them
so i i do my best with turning things
around
right now i gotta go on the ninth
and uh try to get some restitution
and go up against somebody because i
agreed with the police that i was going
to do it but i didn't know that he was a
gang member and so
i i'm i'm learning i keep i keep my cup
empty
so that i can keep learning the martial
arts was a big thing
and going towards each time when i
thought that i was going to die
i went around
passing things out and giving people
things to people that i thought i could
trust you know the martial arts
the mythology
the different things that from being a
book reader i had a metaphysical
bookstore in sedona when i went to
sedona after show business
and there was a lot of self-help books
and i started to work with that with dr
bernie siegel's love medicine and
miracles as the name of the book
i sold a lot of that book but i got a
lot of good understanding and that
helped me through the cancers my my wife
had had a cancer where they took off
part of her face
and then it didn't heal up and that
and
the good thing about my wife was she put
me
back on the track
and we did a lot of partying but i
agreed that i wanted to live
and i wanted to end the partying but
when i came back to la the partying
started
and the partying destroyed us just like
it's destroying these people and
i tried to work with the police but i
don't want to be a snitch and i don't
want to work with
ice or the fbi because when this thing
happened with this guy that knocked me
down recently
they all tried to get me to work with
them
because i still have my mind but my my
thing is is helping people and helping
people outside and the older people that
are new because it isn't just the people
on the drugs
and with the crystal meth
it's not just these homeless people like
they think at three o'clock in the
morning when i'm near the canary club
it's young college kids asking for it
and once it gets in the mind
they're asking anyone for it they'll ask
a priest they'll ask a detective you
know they got to have that so
the the the thing outside where people
are using the band-aids is not good
and just hurting people like internment
camps
and putting people into places where
they can get their drugs from other
people in a group is not the answer to
the the answer is helping people
like when they have places like a place
called path and that
so that people can get
geared back into repairing their life
and working not sitting around getting
comfortable the bad thing on the street
is to get comfortable i mean it doesn't
make sense but it
once you get comfortable and you got
that tent and all that you're finished
you're saying like this is it this is
all where i can go
this is the best that i can do
and it isn't because because i have
helped people
i get i've got a lot of people into
harvey's apartments where i stayed and
then i told them pay the rent first so
it's up to them and then i saw them
i had my little bit of smoke my rent was
paid
they they had an ounce
and then next thing they were outside
so it's
keeping the place too when you have it
because there's a lot of people that get
places they're first to give these
places to these drug addicts and these
people well here i am 72 i worked all my
life that's a frustrating thing to want
a place
and see that these other people that
don't want and are right back outside
dealing their drugs
and
the easy way because it's a good life if
you don't weaken
you have to be strong to last long
what was the best time of your life the
best time of my life was uh i had hooked
up with a a a famous lady an actress
named diane ladd
and laura dern and i had my uh
people were coming over to sedona to my
art gallery and and uh taking me out to
dinner and i was treated very special
but when i was in show business and my
name was up there and and i was doing it
i really enjoyed it but i had to escape
because of the party and the people that
i knew and that's all that they did
and when i lost freddy prince richard
pryor another guy jumped from the hyatt
i said
this is not me because it was i wasn't
satisfied i enjoyed it
and when i got up it was the greatest
high because all these people have all
this love
and and people from out of town want
autographs
and that
but uh
it was time
because i wanted to live
so it was your decision to get out of
show vision yeah
and i'm trying now desperately to get
off the streets and do what i have to do
and it's hard because
they don't provide
places for you to charge your phone and
you're running around trying to people
try to get a hold of you and your phone
is not charged
and all that stuff that happened with
covert where we couldn't get a good
heart meal so i'll go to saint joseph's
and they'll give me a hot meal
i had trouble for for 60 days i couldn't
get my mail
my wallet i have to get all my paperwork
all my
cards
and then when you don't have id they
don't want to give it to you and i say i
need all this to get into a place but uh
the paperwork constantly with the
paperwork constantly what they call an
awards letter
which shows you how much ssi and how
much disability
and hearing yourself so
you don't want to lose your disability
but unless you've got some kind of job
but me
with
being told cause of two different
cancers a throat cancer and a prostate
uh
recently when i got hit my blood count
went up my white cells to 20
and so i have that thing where i've got
to get it together and get it get into a
a place and and i don't really want to
go to jack in the box and die here
but i but i need some extra money you
know so
i have to do what i have to do in life
to be 72 and homeless is this
discouraging it must be is this your
lowest point in your life
no no i had much
lower things
obstacles that i had to go through in
that what was your most difficult period
uh when i was on probation i had to work
in the steel mill
and i had to deal with all these older
people and i had my long hair so some of
it i brought on myself but i would go up
into canada
and and help people there
and i lost the good friends that
really tight friends stand up people
people who do anything for you because
that's the way that i was
and uh that war took some of those
people and some of those people couldn't
come back
so i used to go up into ottawa
but
the
the thing with the homeless thing is
that i have all these fractures so i
basically don't sleep through the night
and i got to stay up because of the
crystal methods
because
they they come to you
and
you try to help them and when they don't
have they get hostile there's a lot of
hostile with it probably the guy that
hit me and knocked me down
had to learn something about older
people fighting back because they're
attacking older people
so i went to court because of that
and to stand up for older people
as well as to stand up for myself
and so i tried to keep
a little bit of sleep and do the things
to make me healthy to get through the
cancer but i'm lucky that i have
somebody i have somebody that i can help
somebody that
i can talk to
that i'm not out there talking to by
myself when i came out here i tried to
figure it out myself and i found out
that maybe 90
of the people
that were going through what they threw
went through with mail
wasn't alco just alcohol and drugs
their situation was they had difficulty
with a woman or it ended and they didn't
bounce back and that had happened to me
after my wife left me
i i didn't want to have and i was just
sitting there all alone but luckily i
had been through the drug scenario and
knew that that was nowhere
tell me about recovering from adversity
in life
recovering from adversity in life is is
finding some kind of spirituality in
their life
some kind of reason to say that uh
it is necessary to to forget it's
easier when you're older to lose your
vanity in self-centeredness that's what
i'm working on
uh
adversity comes from uh
those
we say in zen in the martial arts a book
i helped put together
that
there's always one more mountain to
climb there's always going to be like
all right i had this happen and you're
talking to god and you're saying
what's next
how how can i keep doing this and and
some people come by and and say to you
well
uh god wouldn't give put anything on
your plate that you couldn't handle but
when you're 140 pounds
and you've got chemo
and you can't eat
and
you're dying
sometimes god places somebody else
that's the thing about going up against
the adversity because the chemo i think
would probably be the lowest even though
i talked about the other things
and that i looked in for the christ part
that was in me instead of out there
and it said you better get out there
and that was april it's been almost two
years
and uh get the sea air
they said i wouldn't walk i'd do the
steps
and yeah you seemed very healthy for
yeah i said to your age
well i always had the thing even when i
was sick that i looked good i had
trouble with my mother because i would
be really sick
and and i tried to explain that to her
that i would still look okay
but uh i tried to keep from getting
negative are trying to keep from uh
getting feeling those thoughts of
suicide and the other things
and that that there there might be
something else that we try to believe in
that's on the other side that keeps us
going the sense you hear today
that answers our prayers
and that and that's the jump on
on on on all those bad things because
when you've had
you get a cancer and then you get hit by
a car
and my lady said it was really hot why
are you putting on all these clothes i
said well i don't want anyone to see my
splits because it's like these people
are like birds
with dead animals like buzzards they hit
on you
there's a lot of good people helping too
i don't want it to be that there's
people coming by but you're constantly
up against you've got to be strong
because these people will attack you and
they try to steal your stuff they're
stealing stuff all the time the first
time when i was homeless
we didn't have the crystal there were
some other problems
but it wasn't like the people attacking
people and and the people dying out
there and i resuscitated a guy the other
day and he was asking me and i don't
know if he's running a game on me he
said
i need to have some kind of uh
birthday celebration i said well i'll
give you a few bucks but not enough for
you to get your thing in it because i
knew he did crystal and i said you know
you were the guy i helped resuscitate
the other night and you were gone for 12
seconds
and here he still wanted it
so
so all we can do to keep going is try to
affect some kind of spirituality i go to
metropolis for the meal i send people
there and i try not to think of my own
self i see people in a lot worse shape
but like the guy was talking to
well i have a great zen
that i go and i'm able to shoot pool i
used to hustle pool
so i'm able to go and and shoot my pool
and then i escaped from everything in my
mind and all these things that i'm going
on
and when i go out everyone wants to talk
about their suffering
and don juan
in this book with castaneda that he
wrote about he said
that most
older peop men
sat around talking about their suffering
and i didn't want to be that so i got a
lot on my plate but i don't want to go
there there's a guy like seinfeld that i
have to escape because he wants to talk
about prostate cancer
in the science of mind it is better to
dissolve that name that they give
and so dr bernie siegel said the same
thing when i started working with
healing and healing with people and the
flower working with the flower remedies
uh
yeah that that was a big thing he said
that they would give names like when
when i first started before the cancer
they said i had diverticulitis because i
couldn't stop bleeding
well the guy that i went in
with they said you're really lucky he's
not coming home
and when i went in with with the chemo
to go back because i know my transition
is amazing that
he was there and he was saying okay
uh
i'm giving up and they wouldn't let him
eat and he said
you don't understand i can't go back to
highland park he had done a lot of
things and he used to be 225 and he was
139 and he says these people
will eat him up they'll destroy him
so i think
having the spirituality even if people
look at me and like i was reading the
bible when you came
i i am
psalm 143
where i was laid low
and i was brought back
so that knowing that
gives me
that courage to keep doing it
because i can help others
but i got to help myself if i got to get
72 and
being this you know
to get up in the morning and it's cold
and you're in pain
all the time you say you know there's
got to be more
i will do what i have to do but i do get
brought low and and i do
have to take my time to to rest in that
but uh
the band-aids that they give and these
things like with internment camps are
not helping they need to do more with
helping people
to to get their way out to develop their
life
that's all that i have to say okay
david thank you so much for sharing your
story
god bless you i wish you the best of
luck out there all right thank you very
much
you